Politicians realize that non-verbals are important.
And so when they choose an outfit,
when they choose how they're going to come out,
whether or not they're going to be smiling or shaking hands,
one thing I can assure you,
this has been rehearsed many times it is theater,
it's absolute theater.
And one of the things that we will be looking for is how well these actors do
their job.
My name's Joe Navarro. And for 25 years,
I was a spy catcher with the FBI.
And I am a nonverbal communications expert.
As we approach the height of the political season.
The question I'm asked is, you know, what do you look for?
And the body language of the people that will be in the
debates. I look at everything that's involved because we have to look at all the
non-verbals, right?
Just when the candidates come on stage, um,
they're always waving at somebody in the audience or pointing a finger and so
forth.
Sometimes these are actually bogus gestures because they know the camera's
in the audience will take pictures anytime there's a large gesture.
And so they may actually do these things with no one in mind.
You'll notice that rarely are debaters allowed to
stand or sit close to each other.
Usually there's at least seven to 10 feet of space.
And the reason for that is debaters.
Actually don't want you to see that there is a height difference.
And so by separating the two individuals,
we don't notice that difference.
You'll see an unusual amount of the color blue in the background,
somewhere between the color of the ocean and the sky,
which is soothing to the human brain,
the wearing of a Navy blue suit,
white shirts, often a red or burgundy tie.
Subconsciously we see the significance of that because it is
what we see in the American flag. Red, white,
and blue what's really become ubiquitous is the
lapel pen of the American flag.
This is something that 30 years ago, even 20 years ago,
we hardly saw. But now it's almost part of our attire. You know,
if you think about it,
is someone less patriotic because on this day they're not wearing the American
flag. Of course not. This is reaching out to you at a subconscious level.
It's part of the theater, part of the orchestration,
which we now, uh.
We're looking for.
Or their behaviors to see are these with what we have seen in the past.
We certainly shouldn't be using body language to try to determine if they're
speaking the truth.
These are orchestrated events and that's not what we use body language
for. We use body language to supplement and
confirm what we are seeing.
Are the words being supported by the gestures,
or are their gestures taking away from their words?
What I look for is, as the moderator asks the question,
do I see lip biting?
Do I see any kind of ventilating behavior such as pulling on the collar?
Do I see any kind of facial distress?
Do I see furrowing of the forehead?
They can in fact take care of it if he just stay out of the way. Oh really?
Oh really? Here's the thing.
The thing that might indicate to me that the individual doesn't
like the question he or she is being asked.
Would you shut up? Listen, who is the other.
Thing I look for is any kind of hesitation throat clear?
Are you willing tonight to condemn white supremacists
specifically, perhaps.
The raising of a shoulder, the lowering of a shoulder.
Stand back and stand by anything.
That conveys lack of confidence. I want to see the hands.
I want to see those thumbs that come up because when we're confident,
the thumbs pop up, when we lack confidence, they come down.
I want to see if there's any kind of stapling.
Stapling is a high indicator of confidence,
or do we see the interlacing of the fingers,
which is I'm struggling with something or I'm having difficulty.
One of the ones that you may not even think about, nothing will ever be said,
but you'll see behaviors like the light touching of the eye with the
fingertip.
This is both a blocking behavior and a comforting behavior.
One of the facial nerves that attends to the eyelid.
The minute we put pressure on that nerve,
it begins to send messages to the brain to calm down. What,
in essence they're saying is I screwed up or I really don't like that.
One of the things that happens in political debates are the things that we never
planned for, for instance, in 2016. Now,
president Trump walking behind Hillary Clinton during the
debates, it almost looked like he was stalking her. I mean,
I can just imagine me trying to talk to the camera right now with somebody
loitering behind me that actually actuates a limbic
response.
So we may see behaviors that arise as a
result of the action of another candidate.
And we certainly saw that in 2016, when, uh,
some candidates refused to shake the hands of others or when
humor was used, when it really wasn't well-intended.
And that's when we see authenticity,
that's when we really see what is in the heart and the mind and the sentiment
of this individual and how they react to it.
Gestures and communication are all
intertwined. They're not two separate things.
We know that because we've done research.
And when we restrict people's hands,
they in fact have less recall.
They're in fact less energetic and they communicate much
less. We used to say, you know, when somebody in authority, gestures,
they need to adjust your wide and they need to gesture smoothly.
And of course in the zoom world,
those gestures need to be up here where people can see them.
Humans are so sensitive to non-verbals that if I were to
point my finger at the audience and say, you,
we actually have a visceral reaction to that, which is usually very negative.
And I think about how many times a school teacher has called on us.
And it's gone like that.
We know that if we turn that gesture into an open Palm vertical gesture,
we like that.
We prefer that probably the most popular one is this thumb
gesture that you often see the candidate is making a point
and the thumb is just barely sticking out from beyond the index
finger. Anytime we grasp something, we're saying,
I'm talking to you about something that's important to me,
I'm sort of grasping it, which has to be differentiated for instance,
for when we talk. And we say with precision,
so this is a precision grip. I want you to think about this.
So some of the other gestures we'll see is the open Palm gesture shows that
we're open, that we are receptive. The palms are up,
the fingers are wide. Um, this is a very appealing.
Some of the other gestures we may see is if the person is doing
this.
So normally a Baton gesture is a cadence behavior that
denotes, I am asking you to come visit me.
But when we do it this way, what we're in fact, uh,
saying if we slow it down is I'm really not so much behind
that because it's literally pushing away rather than being
receptive. The other behavior we may see is, um,
the touching of the heart and the chest,
which we often see portrayed as so-called honesty displays.
They are in fact neutral because I've seen both individuals that are guilty
of crimes and the innocent use this gesture.
So it gives the appearance of being honest,
but it doesn't mean that they're being honest.
So one of the questions I'm asked is do politicians rehearse their hand
gestures?
Some do some don't some absolutely refuse to receive any kind of
training. Others are well coached. The question is, you know,
how much of it is authentically theirs and how much of it is
a borrowed. Usually if they've been in office a long time,
or they've been in politics for a long time,
they will be reluctant to change any of their numbers.
Let's look at president Trump's gestures.
His most favored one is to talk with the index finger, to the thumb.
Glorious nation under God. Sometimes.
He does the elbow flop as he's emphasizing.
I don't see any protests.
Oftentimes his eyelids will come down to block when he's hearing something,
he doesn't like,
you can see the money pinches the corner of his mouth when he's being
sarcastic or exercising disdain or contempt.
He does the lip pers when he disagrees or doesn't like a question being asked.
And then of course he does the lip poll when he definitely doesn't like the
question being asked. And if you notice,
anytime he's sitting in the white house, surrounded by people,
he always hugs himself. And yet when you compare him to,
when he's on his show, the apprentice, he always has a territorial display.
And you see this contrast and you have to ask yourself,
why do we see this behavior on a TV show and
why we're not seeing this? Um, in a, in a presidential cabinet,
let's look at Joe Biden's gestures.
He does a lot of lip touching. We call it a pensive behavior.
You often see it as people are pondering when he's making a point, uh,
he tends to Pharaoh, his glabella, he squints his eyes.
Voice often is lowered for emphasis. You should go out and vote.
And as with many people, um, when something bothers him,
the lips disappear. And this is something that I'm often asked about.
Does this have anything to do with the section?
And it has absolutely nothing to do with deception.
These are the behaviors that we adopt and that we use that
help us to communicate what we're thinking about at that
moment.
Rarely do people remember what is said,
but we tend to remember the images to this day.
We still teach about, uh,
governor Dukakis on a military tank wearing this tankers helmet
and how odd he'd looked. And, you know,
we scoffed sometimes at the non-verbals.
And yet here was one that we can clearly show that just from a pairing
on that tank, it really diminished his posture.
You know,
some people see these behaviors as a short hand,
I wouldn't call it that behaviors,
gestures are part of communication.
We have primarily communicated non-verbally.
We find ourselves using these gestures all the time,
and there's a reason for it. People usually respond to them.
People that know us well respond to them.
And so we don't separate them as ancillary to
communication. They are in fact, part of community.
[Inaudible].